[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's the pink feather jackets for me
headliner harry styles and lizzo give
the show-stopping performance we never
knew we needed as they perform a duet of
gloria gainers i will survive at
coachella
[Music]
on friday the watermelon sugar singer
surprised the audience when he brought
lizzo on stage and along with rocking
out to the beloved classic i will
survive the two also took part in
another duet singing one directions 2011
hit song what makes you beautiful
[Music]
for both performances the pair
coordinated in hot pink outfits and
following their time on stage lizzo
shared this video on tick tock recapping
her night with the as it was singer
[Music]
[Applause]
i got to watch side stage
[Music]
lizzo also took to instagram to
commemorate the special occasion by
posting a selfie with harry captioning
it quote proud of you harry styles thank
you for having me
coachella isn't the first time harry and
lizzo have teamed up in 2020 lizzo
brought the 28 year old on stage at
fillmore miami beach to perform her hit
song juice
[Music]
now back to coachella lizzo's surprise
performance with harry was a follow-up
to another big surprise on weekend one
of the festival
when harry brought out one of his own
inspirations country legend shania twain
[Music]
they gave a stadium-worthy performance
as they belted out twain's man i feel
like a woman and her classic you're
still the one
[Music]
this was a dream come true for harry who
told et almost five years ago how much
the country star means to him
i think both music and fashion main
influence was
was probably shania twain
yeah i just think she's great
[Music]